this morning the vatican has released
its investigation of
theodore mccarrick who used to be one of
america's most powerful religious
leaders
he now lives in disgrace ousted as a
roman catholic cardinal for the sexual
abuse of a minor
and young men studying for the
priesthood this report names
other high-ranking officials who knew
about the allegations
but did nothing chris livesay is in rome
chris
this report goes right to the very top
doesn't it
well that's right anthony this
long-awaited report admits that pope
john paul ii who made mccarrick a
cardinal and appointed him to washington
d.c
knew about allegations of sexual
misconduct but chose
to ignore them and to instead take
mccarrick
for his word we're in control this will
never happen again
theodore mccarrick the former archbishop
of washington d.c
and an advisor of pontiffs seemed above
reproach
then last year pope francis defrocked
him for sexually abusing minors and
adult seminarians
making mccarrick now 90 years old the
highest ranking official
ever forced out of the priesthood in
modern times
damning evidence showed church officials
knew about his wrongdoing
for years who exactly were his enablers
and how this was swept under the rug
were questions that have burned for more
than two years
ever since francis ordered this report
by the vatican secretariat of state
which helped propel mccarrick to the top
of the church hierarchy
francis has promised victims to quote
follow the path of truth
wherever it may lead now with this long
overdue report
they hope mccarrick's fall from grace
will also lead to consequences
and prevention
now the report goes on to say that pope
benedict did take the allegations more
seriously
but not seriously enough to initiate a
canonical
trial now the report is more than 400
pages long and we've only just now
received a copy
so further revelations may yet come to
light
gail got to get your speed reading
skills ready chris livesay reporting
from rome thank you very much